right I want to bring you some breaking
news because the United Nations Human
Rights Council is holding an urgent
meeting on the burning of a Quran which
took place in Sweden last month the
meeting was requested by Pakistan let's
have a listen to uh what they have to
say the freedom of opinion and
expression we look forward to adopting a
draft resolution on countering religion
hatred constituting incitement to
discrimination hostility or violence in
order to consolidate the principles of
human rights to conclude with like to
stress that freedom of expression is an
ethical value that should spread
peaceful co-existence rather than
causing Clash of civilizations we should
spread the values of Tolerance and put
an end to all practices of hatred and
discrimination the universal culture of
peace and tolerance can only be built
through concerted International efforts
to
ensure their respect for everyone in all
societies peace be upon you all
thank you now let me invite Pakistan his
Excellency billable
Minister for foreign affairs of Pakistan
through video
Mr President High Commissioner
excellencies I thank the Human Rights
Council for holding this urgent debate
three months ago we observed the first
International Day to combat islamophobia
wherein our capacity is OIC chair we had
the privilege to co-check along the unsg
and the unpga the first ever session to
Mark the occasion of the U.N General
Assembly unanimously we all spoke with
one voice in condemnation of
islamophobia
unfortunately the the deliberate
desecration of the Holy Quran has
continued under government sanction and
with a sense of impunity
increasingly these acts are designed to
maximize provocation
we must see this clearly for what it is
incitement to religious hatred
discrimination and attempts to provoke
violence we must join hands in
condemning it we must isolate those who
Stoke hatred Mr President
the Holy Quran is a spiritual anchor for
billion Muslims it is inseparable from
their sense of identity and dignity it
is important to understand the Deep hurt
that a public and premeditated Act of
the quran's desecration causes to
Muslims it is an attack on their faith
the call in the tech in the draft text
before this Council for prevention and
accountability is therefore reasonable
and necessary in making this call I'm
not losing sight of the fundamental
right of free speech free speech is as
indispensable as hate speech should be
indefensible our Vigor to protect Free
Speech must not lose sight of the
imperative to reject hate speech there
is not a single Muslim country on the
planet that allows for the DraStic
desecration of holy texts of other
religions such an act is Unthinkable to
any Muslim it is forbidden by Faith by
culture and by law it is in the same
spirit I resolutely stand alongside
those who are calling for prevention
legal deterrence and accountability of
actions that constitute incitement and
hostility against people of Faith Mr
President let us unite against hatred
discrimination intolerance and forged
Pathways for mutual respect
understanding and tolerance thank you
I thank you the next speaker is Qatar
his Excellency
minister of State for international
cooperation
at the outset we welcome the unanimous
agreements of the HRC to convene this
urgent debate which addresses an
important topic that falls within its
mandate namely addressing religious
hatred which constitutes incitement to
discrimination hostility and violence
weaken them in the strongest terms all
public incidents of burning copies of
the Holy Quran especially those that
took place in a number of European
countries
at the time when the whole world is
facing daunting challenges
we have a selective standards
anti-Semitism for example can be
addressed a number of countries magnify
what happens to minorities and magnify
what happens to others
and they call upon other countries to
change the methodology Mr President this
important discussion is an opportunity
to shed light on religious minorities
all over the world that is not limited
to a certain religion in European
countries many practices and laws do not
respect racial diversity including
Muslims another problem that Muslims
face in a Far East is
discriminatory
practices where we have a confusion of
the ethnic and religious discrimination
which may cause the death of people in
Qatar we call upon these countries to
take a national measures to address the
said and to hold perpetrators
accountable and to prevent recurrence
thank you very much
thank you if you're just uh joining us
what we've been uh watching is the
United Nations Human Rights Council
which is currently holding an urgent
meeting on the burning of the Quran
which took place in Sweden last month we
heard a little earlier from the
Pakistan's representative the minister
for foreign affairs bilawal Bhutto
Pakistan one of several countries who
actually has requested this meeting from
the Human Rights Council the UN Human
Rights Council and also demanded
International response we also heard
there from qatar's representative
Ministry of state of cooperation let's
speak to our correspondent worry
challenge who's been following this
story
before we talk any further give us a
little bit of background to what exactly
happened about a month ago in Sweden
when when this Quran was burnt
so essentially an Iraqi Christian
immigrant Burns a copy of the Quran
outside a Stockholm mosque during Eid
al-adda it was an incidence that
basically caused a significant amount of
outrage around the world particularly in
Muslim countries there was widespread
condemnation the Swedish Embassy in
Baghdad was was briefly stormed by Angry
protesters followers of the Shiite
cleric mukhtar al-sada
Muslim countries such as Pakistan
urged Sweden to enact a ban on the
burning of the Quran the Swedish
governments came out and said that it
did strongly reject the islamophobic
acts committed by individuals in Sweden
and added that this in no way reflected
the opinions of the Swedish government
but
essentially doing this thing burning a
Quran is not a legal under Swedish law
the police have tried to stop uh planned
burnings of of the Quran or any other
book but the court said no that this is
protected as part of Sweden's uh free
speech legislation there are those in
Sweden who say that this crosses over uh
Free Speech into hate speech which is
illegal but at the moment the Swedish
courts aren't supporting that that
perspective at its heart really this is
one of those you know repeated clashes
that we have seen over many many years
this tension between
the the laws in some European countries
which enshrine uh free speech is pretty
much uh sacrosanct even when
um it might offends the beliefs of
religious minorities within that country
versus you know the the beliefs in in
many Islamic countries around the world
perhaps more conservative ones that hold
up certain items such as the Quran as
being absolutely holy and therefore any
desecration of them is is considered
Blasphemous we've seen this time and
time again and it is going to continue
okay thank you for that Rory challenge
there for us in London